- Good evening.
I'm happy to welcome you all to the last
of this year's Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
here at the Whitney Humanities Center.
Each year, the annual Franke
Lectures in the Humanities,
are organized in conjunction
with an upper level
undergraduate humanities seminar.
The lectures are made possible
by the generosity of Richard
and Barbara Franke,
and are intended to
present important topics
in the humanities to wide
and general audience.
The fall 2021 Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
have been organized in conjunction
with the Yale College seminar
Mass Incarceration in the Soviet Union
and the United States.
Taught by professors, Timothy
Snyder, and Jason Stanley.
Tonight, we are pleased and
honored to welcome Lori Gruen.
Professor Gruen is the
William Griffin Professor
of Philosophy at Wesleyan University.
She is the author or editor of 15 books
and dozens of important
chapters and articles.
She works at the intersection
of practical ethics
and political philosophy.
Gruen is a founding faculty member
and the creator of the
Faculty Advisory Committee
of the Center for Prison
Education at Wesleyan University.
She has taught incarcerated students
at Bayview Correctional Facility,
a women's prison in Chelsea,
New York now closed,
the Federal Correction Institution
in Danbury, Connecticut,
when it was a women's prison,
and Cheshire Correctional Institution
in Cheshire, Connecticut, a
maximum security men's prison,
and York Correctional
Institution, a women's prison.
And today she will present
her paper on carceral logic,
professor Gruen, pick it away.
- Thank you so much, Professor Stanley,
I'm honored to be here.
One of the things that
I'm going to do tonight
is to talk through two
really conceptual ideas,
carceral logics on the one hand
and an abolitionist critique on the other,
and I realized that for many of you,
it's the end of the semester.
I understand that there's a lot going on.
So I really appreciate your being here.
I also made some slides
that I'm gonna share now.
And so at least you'll
be able to follow along
since we don't have handouts and the like.
So as Professor Stanley said,
my talk is entitled
Carceral Logics: An Abolitionist Critique.
You may remember that
afternoon, last April 20th,
like many people across the U.S.
you may have been tensely waiting to learn
what the Minneapolis jury would
decide in the murder trial
of former police officer Derek Chauvin,
who killed George Floyd.
Due to the pandemic we all
were able to watch the trial,
and that would only have
been witnessed by family
and locals if we weren't in a pandemic.
But as the judge read out the verdicts
on the three charges against Chauvin,
second degree murder, guilty,
third degree murder, guilty,
and second degree manslaughter, guilty,
there was a collective
national sigh of relief,
and the reaction was emotional.
Television news cutaway from
regularly scheduled programming
to broadcast some of the reactions.
The Congressional Black
Caucus members for example,
were shown huddled together
looking at their phones
and other devices,
nodding, hugging as they
listened to the verdicts.
Citizens outside the courthouse
also watched on their phones they cheered,
fists were raised high,
many people looked up in
the heavens in gratitude.
People held each other and
some broke down and wept.
There was a similar, although
more muted emotional relief
when the three men that
gunned down Ahmaud Arbery
were convicted a few weeks ago,
and a great deal of anger was generated
when Kyle Rittenhouse was found not guilty
of shooting three White men
and killing two of them,
Joseph Rosenbaum and Anthony Hoover.
It's undeniable that many
people felt deeply gratified
by the carceral responses
to Chauvin's callous cruelty
and the conviction of the
men who killed Arbery.
So many police officers and
vigilantes are not arrested
or tried or convicted of horrible crimes
against Black people and
sometimes White people.
And so I want you to keep that feeling
of wanting to punish close
while I talk about the
logics that underlie it
and why I think we need to break free
of these punitive impulses
and abolish carceral logics.
In this talk, I'll briefly unpack
and explore various ways
that carceral logics shape,
excuse me, various ways
that carceral logic
shape our social and political relations.
These harmful carceral logics, I'll argue,
hold us all captive and
systems of disposability,
permanent exclusions and
they should be abolished.
But let's start first
by talking about how I
understand carceral logics.
It has a lot of different meanings,
and I wanna be sure that
we all are on the same page
with what I think carceral logics are.
So one way of thinking about
it is that it highlights
and organizes the variety
of ways that our bodies
and our minds and our actions
have been shaped by the idea
and practices of captivity
even for people who
haven't been to prison.
And I want to just take
a moment here especially
to say something about
those of us who think about
and talk about prisons,
who haven't been in prison.
That is those of us who
haven't been locked up,
I mean, I've been in a lot of prisons
as Professor Stanley just
said, but that isn't important.
Those who are incarcerated
or formerly incarcerated
are really the best people
to talk about the weight
of carceral power,
and how they've experienced
it in their bodies and minds
and we have a lot to learn from them.
I'll draw on their voices
and what they've taught
me throughout my talk,
but part of the reason that I'm interested
in talking about not
carceral power per se,
but carceral logics is that
it's an ideology of capture
and containment that impacts all of us.
Those who are incarcerated,
those who are formerly incarcerated,
and those of us not yet incarcerated.
I wanna explore what sort of thinking
these carceral logics make possible,
and perhaps more importantly,
what sorts of ideas and
practices they authorize
and what sorts of ideas and
practices they foreclose.
I'll identify two types
of carceral logics.
The first is a carceral
logic as understood
is sort of organizing, capture,
surveillance, and disposal,
and I'll talk a little bit about that.
And then I'm going to turn
to a second type of carceral logic,
which I think of as an
ideology of domination,
and I'll say a little
bit about domination.
And then after I talk about
these carceral logics,
and you get a sense of what I mean,
I will then turn to talking
about why we should abolish them
and how that might look.
Okay, and I'm thinking that
most everyone in the audience today
has some sense of the sort of shape
of the actual carceral system
that the sort of bricks
and mortar and razor wire.
So I'm not gonna talk too much about that.
As I said it's a little
bit more conceptual
what I'm gonna be talking about,
but when we imprison humans,
I'm gonna just say a
little bit now about it.
When we in prison humans,
we harm them in ways
that are both obvious,
they're in conditions that
can cause physical suffering
and frustration and ways
that are not so obvious.
Long-term psychological
impacts of boredom,
anxiety, and a lack of control.
Here's how a group of incarcerated men
who were sentenced collectively
to a total of 225 years
in a maximum security prison
describe a slice of their experiences.
And this is from a chapter
that they wrote in my edited volume,
the volume's called the
Ethics of Captivity.
And this piece that this
comes from is as you see here,
life behind bars.
So what they say, and
you could read along,
"After our initial humiliation
upon being strip searched
when we enter prison, we lose
all control of our lives.
We will eat, bathe, and shave when told.
We'll be expected to follow direct orders,
no matter how absurd or unfair.
Noncompliance will be met with force,
the depressive environment
tends to stifle intellectual curiosity.
We simply become too tired
and Sullen to engage in
intellectual pursuits.
Simply put, we dwell in ourselves,
we're not actively using our minds,
and in a very real sense,
we're thus losing our minds.
The loneliness caused
by prisons in general
and prison cells in
particular is exacerbated
by the loss of intimacy
and the loving touch
of friends and family."
Those held captive are deprived so much,
including the ability
to make basic choices.
Of course, none of us is free
to make any kind of choices we might want.
We're restricted in all sorts of ways
by the genders that were assigned,
by our physical and cognitive
abilities, by class,
by religion, by race, by
ethnicity, even by our species.
We're restricted by state power
and other governmental
and economic institutions
that prescribe all sorts of choices
and force others upon us.
Carceral prison spaces
are particularly stark
in their ways of limiting
and reducing the choices
that are available
for those who are within them,
cages and cells and iron
doors, little natural light,
concrete and steel, razor
wire, and metallic noise.
And these carceral spaces
are designed in part
and organized by a carceral logic
that makes these choices impossible.
But there are carceral spaces
that function beyond prisons
and Gulags and those also
control and contain others,
immigration detention centers, zoos,
laboratories, psychiatric institutions,
even some senior living places
are sites of containment,
surveillance, and control.
They're also often sites of undoing.
The carceral spaces
are not simply punitive
and they do not merely serve as Fuko noted
as socializing and
disciplining institutions
and to sites of surveillance.
Increasingly we're seeing
that they also function
to reinforce a permanent state of injury.
And part of that injury
is the disposability
of those who occupy those spaces.
Some humans have always fallen
into the category of
disposable or fungible.
People stolen from Africa
and the transatlantic slave
trade are prime examples,
but there are an estimated
27 million people
in slavery today.
Kevin Bales in his book,
"Disposable People,"
conservatively estimates
that a larger, sorry,
a larger number of people
than the whole population
of Canada are currently enslaved.
The bulk of these people,
approximately 15 to 20 million,
are in conditions of
bounded labor in India,
Pakistan, Bangladesh, and Nepal.
They become enslaved as
security against alone,
or when they inherited debt.
In other words, these
persons have a price.
I won't go into cons at this moment,
but if those of you who are
aware of con will now recognize
that these disposable beings
with a price are mirror things.
And then when they don't
work to their capacity,
they're disposed of.
When you're disposable,
you have lesser status.
Sometimes the status is
the status of a thing,
and this isn't only a
slight or an affront,
but a way of reminding both
the one being denied the status
and others around
that one is in the category
deemed disposable abject other.
That's one way that the carceral logics
that I'm worried about operate.
The other kind of logic, as I mentioned,
is one of domination.
There are at least two ways
that we can think of domination.
One that supports
and maintains not just
disciplinary control of bodies,
but taxonomies of power,
the other upholds ontological
exclusions or outsideness
and the violence it authorizes.
The first sort of domination
is characterized by its justicetory power
upholding oppressive institutions,
relationships, and practices.
Domination according to political
philosopher Philip Pettit
occurs when a person is in a position
in which someone has the
power to arbitrarily interfere
with choices they would
otherwise have been able to make.
And this notion of domination
is pretty expansive
because the interference
just needs to be possible
in the form of a threat.
It has wide reaching ramifications
and that one can internalize
the potential to be the
victim of domination
and one can imagine one
has the power to dominate
and so act as if it's their privilege,
and this way of thinking naturalizes
or normalizes domination.
Remedying this sort of carceral logic
is important in many
contexts when the dominator
and the dominated exist on the same plane
when they are at the
same table as it were.
What I'm thinking of here is that
the relationship of
dominated and dominator
or the dominator and the submissive,
this may be a relationship
in which both are recognized
as having a capacity to switch roles.
And the roles are just at
this particular juncture
because of particular
political and social,
and probably historical
features of the situation
end up having that divergent
relationship of domination
and submission but it's a
kind of fixable domination
as it were.
If you think about the example also,
I was thinking teachers and students,
there's a certain relation of
power there, but domination,
but like overt domination
that's objectionable domination,
not just the relationship of power,
but the objectively problematic domination
can be called out by the student.
Similarly, students have
certain amount of power.
They can also be called out by a teacher
about their abuse of that power.
So what I'm getting at here is
that this particular version
of domination sort of recognized
the possibility of remedy,
but there's a deeper type of injury
associated with carceral
logics of domination.
For whom domination is a
condition of existence.
This is what I meant earlier
when I said it has an ontological flavor.
The idea here is that there's
a category, the slave,
the prisoner, the animal,
and their category is
fundamentally lower status.
There's no way of to this
domination relationship.
It's the condition of existence.
This carceral logic that
these categorical individuals
are subjected to go as beyond
this first sort of domination.
Here is a logic that serves
as a conceptual mechanism
that fixes and solidifies exclusions.
It permanently marks another as an other.
This sort of carceral logic
is especially obvious in
anti-Black racism, for example.
Okay, so this was my brief discussion
of two types of carceral logic
that I'm concerned about.
We can talk more, I hope we will later,
but these carceral logics organize
our systems of captivity for humans
and I should add also for animals
and they structure domination
that consistently denies many humans
the very chance of being free.
Carceral logics have
also colonized our minds
making it hard to imagine
how we can make any changes.
This is why we have the emotions we have
when Chauvin was found guilty
and why we more often have the
disappointments that we have
when many of those in
power are not charged
or tried or convicted when they
act with egregious violence
against the powerless.
I have those two even
though I've been thinking
about these issues for a really long time,
I still have that.
It's not possible to completely escape
the way in which carceral logics
have colonized our thinking.
It is really hard to get
out of it in other words,
but I think we can abolish
these carceral logics
from our thinking and our
feeling and our acting.
And we can work at least
to free our imaginations
and create the ground to stand
and think against such logics.
And one way we can do that is
by thinking about abolition
and abolition has a lot of different,
again, like carceral logics
abolition is a big category.
There's a lot of different ways
of understanding what it means.
Many people think of it
in terms of the abolition
of prisons themselves,
I'm thinking of it more in this context
as a way of getting
outside of carceral logic.
So abolishing carceral logic,
and I'll talk a little
bit about the history
of abolition as a notion as well,
but I want us to sort of put aside
the notion of abolishing prisons
even though that is not
consistent with what I'm saying,
but it's not the focus
of what I'm talking about
when I'm talking about abolition.
So abolition as I understand
it in this discussion
is a framework for
reimagining our own agency
for reenvisioning our communities
and for reframing our social
and political relations.
In a fairly recent, I think
last year or the year before
New York Times article about geographer
and abolitionists Ruthie Gilmore,
law professor James Forman
Jr. said that quote,
"What I love about abolition
and now using my own thinking,
and when I identify
myself as an abolitionist,
this is what I have in mind
is that the idea that you
imagine a world without prisons,
and then you work to build
that world, or in my terms,
you imagine a world
without carceral logic,
and then you work to build that world."
So abolition is aspirational.
Imagining otherwise moving
against carceral logic,
we'll be trying,
we're asked to think in
fundamentally different ways,
thinking that's contextual,
relational, historical,
maybe even poetic with a little bit
of what Devonya Havis a
philosopher describes as alchemy
will need ingenuity to
negotiate what seems impossible.
So before getting into how we
might move in the direction
of imagining how to
negotiate impossibility
or what seems impossible,
lemme say a little bit about
the history of abolition.
So the term abolition is
best known, of course,
in the context of opposition
to the Atlantic slave trade.
Early abolitionists were opposed
to the violent accumulation
of wealth due to forced labor.
According to Manisha Sinha
in her book, "The Slave's Cause"
abolition is though primarily concerned
with resisting slavery
had wide reaching concerns
and I'll leave this up so you can see
what she thinks as also
being really important,
and a part of what it
was that abolitionists,
the early oven abolitionists were doing.
So with the abolition of
slavery after the civil war,
many abolitionists were
actively reimagining
how to bring the ideals of
democracy into fuller practice.
So democracy was a big commitment
of these early abolitionists
and the abolitionists after
including importantly,
sociologists W. E. B. Du
Bois in Black Reconstruction
noted that abolition democracy
demanded the structural reform of labor,
education, and opportunities.
Now notice, so, we're going
from a thought of abolition
of slavery and forced labor practices
to a different way of thinking
about how to organize our communities
and the opportunities
and resources that are available
within those communities.
So this is important point.
It wasn't enough to emancipate
Black people from slavery,
many envisioned building a free
and equal society in which
the disadvantages that emerged
from the system of slavery
were not permanent.
But as I was suggesting,
the second version of carceral logics
has a kind of afterlife.
And that afterlife is
something that we see
at the end of reconstruction as well.
And the reimplementation
of the Black codes,
which perpetuated forms of
unfreedom for Black people.
For example, they could be prosecuted
for not carrying proof of employment,
which led to incarceration
and with forced labor.
So in the South,
what this mounted to was
a convict leasing program
and the growing population
of Black prisoners
ended up going back to work without pay.
And it was an extraordinarily
abusive system.
Du Bois quotes from a
Southern White woman,
and this is what she says,
in some states where convict labor is sold
to the highest bidder the cruel treatment
of the helpless human chattel
in the hands of guards
is such as no tongue can
tell nor pen picture.
Prison inspectors find
convicts herded together
irrespective of the age
and there were a lot
of children, actually,
a lot of children.
Confined at night in shackles,
housed sometimes as has
been found in old box cars
packed almost as closely
as sardines in a box.
During the day all are
worked under armed guards
who stand ready to shoot down
any who may attempt to escape
from this hell upon earth
the modern American Bastille.
Should one escape the bloodhounds
trained for the purpose
are put upon his tracks
and the chances are that
he will be brought back
severely flogged and put in
double shackles or worse.
As this shocking conditions
of convict leasing
became widely known pressure
built to end the practice
and one by one Southern
states didn't renew the,
or initiate the leases.
Alabama was the final state to
end convict leasing in 1928.
Okay, fast forward, I'm a
philosopher not historian, sorry.
Fast forward to 1970s.
So 1928 to 1970s lots happened,
but we'll just fast forward.
There were a new form of abolition emerged
and that was led a lot by Quakers,
and it was a form of
abolition of against prisons.
And importantly, it's 1976.
So, you know that mass
incarceration wasn't really full on
in that period,
but there were nonetheless
prison abolitionists.
The first chapter of a
book that was put together
by Fay Honey Knopp called
"Instead of Prisons"
with a group of Quakers
and other political actors,
in the first chapter,
they have comments from lawyers
and judges and prisoners
and those employed or formerly
employed by prisons, authors,
activists, and many who condemns prisons,
and these are just some of the examples.
And I think it's really quite striking
how a judge, a professor at Columbia,
a former psychiatrist at Sing Sing
all were in favor of
abolishing the prisons.
And again, this is abolishing prisons
prior to our current era
of mass incarceration.
Okay, that's my brief historical tour.
Now you may have some concerns
and reactions about the idea
of abolition most people do.
It invokes a variety of
different kinds of feelings
like incredulity and disdain
to curiosity and excitement.
And these reactions also
vary depending on the context
in which the topic of
abolition is being raised
and the ways that it's being discussed.
So I wanna give you this
recent example from 2017,
the ACLU conducted a survey
that found that 61% of Americans
believe that people who
suffer from drug addiction
and commit serious crimes
don't belong in prison,
but should receive treatment.
And 87% believe that when people
with mental health disabilities
commit serious crimes
that involve violence,
they should be sent to
mental health programs
where they can receive
treatment from professionals.
So not to prison.
So this is recent, and
this is a huge majority
of the U.S. population.
Such strong public support
for these non-carceral
responses to violent crimes
are I think really important to note
in a country that locks
up over 2 million people,
and as feminist scholar
and abolitionists Joy James has noted
abolitionists alternatives to
prisons are already available
for those with wealth and power.
She writes, existential whiteness,
money, or capital and
connections to governing elites
allow offenders if prosecuted
and convicted to be largely
redirected to therapy,
counseling, drug treatment,
and expensive residential
treatment centers,
but abolishing prisons is
only one way as I've suggested
of thinking about abolition.
I think it's an important project.
Don't get me wrong, I'm
involved in that project,
however, tonight I'm really thinking
of abolishing carceral logics,
and that is consistent as I
said with abolishing prisons,
but I think I'm more interested tonight
in talking about how we
can end our acceptance
of punitive responses to crime
and other acts that are
outside of the accepted norms
and to begin imagining alternatives
to these carceral logics.
In a society like ours
that's organized by
profound and inequality,
abolitionists are working
to develop more just
and meaningful social policy
that will help support community needs
and build alternative humane institutions.
These efforts involve
promoting non-reformist reforms
that are, I think, a really important idea
that allow for the development of policies
and practices that minimize harm,
and also at the same
time don't contribute to,
or reinforce carceral logics.
So let me just give you some examples
of what I think are non-reformist reforms,
we can discuss this further
if this is something
that you either disagree with
or don't think makes sense,
but the program, the Center
for Prison Education,
which is at Wesleyan is a program
that I've been involved
in from the beginning
and also the newer, but also
quite robust program at Yale,
the old Prison Education Initiative
are both what I would call
non-reformist reforms.
What do I mean by that?
I think that part of what
we should be understanding
when we're thinking about
non-reformist reforms
is ways in which some of the
logic of the carceral logic
and the implications of
carceral logic can be undone,
but the prison remains
and the education is happening in prison.
I'm not advocating that
the prisoner remains,
but I'm suggesting that in the moment
when the prison exists,
that it's possible to provide
educational opportunities
that allow those people
who are incarcerated
and able to enroll in various classes
to be able to get there
opportunities that they didn't have
to be exposed to ideas
that they didn't actually
weren't exposed to prior
that they're also able
to develop their own ways
of thinking about themselves
in relationship to others,
in relationship to the state,
in relationship to our fragile democracy
or non-existent democracy
in relation to all sorts of
social and political structures.
So why it's a non-reformist reform
because even though those
of us who do this work
have to abide by the carceral rules
of the departments of correction,
we can work within those systems,
within the first version of
carceral logics to undermine
the very sort of strategies
of carceral logics,
to undermine the very attitudes
that are part of the carceral logic.
I've also included the
Freedom Reads project,
which is another I think
non-reformist reform,
putting freedom libraries,
micro libraries of 500 books into prisons
all across the country,
and I also included here on this slide
some ideas about mutual aid
that has become really important
in the context of the pandemic,
where communities are working together
to help each other outside
of the various systems
that are confining and containing
and have colonized our thinking.
So part of the mutual aid process
has involved redirecting local budgets
to help those who are food
insecure or housing insecure,
or vulnerable to substance use
developing opportunities to support youth,
to creating community-based
harm reduction programs,
working on supporting victims of harm
through restorative justice practices
and holding those who
caused harm accountable
in a non-carceral way as well
as other practical efforts
to build a more caring world.
And these sorts of community programs
I think are extraordinarily meaningful
because they both allow
community accountability,
but then also allow us to
reimagine our social relations
outside of these carceral logics.
Many of you may be thinking,
at least I would have thought
this at one point in my life
that this is all utopian.
This is a kind of utopian notion,
and in some ways I do think that's true.
I think that it may very well be utopian,
but I'm trying to reframe
my thinking about utopia,
and I'll say a bit about that in a sec,
but this is a really,
I think, important insight that I learned
from a philosopher William
Paris who writes that,
"Utopias have been attempts to carve
an alternative space of life
that was sufficiently disconnected
from the dominant social order.
Utopian need not concern itself
with designing a perfect life.
Instead, utopia may take up the task
of creating social spaces
that allow for deliberation
over different ideas about
how we might organize
our social relations.
Utopia is the creation of
an alternative public sphere
for testing out ideas
and disagreements over
novel forms of social life."
So in this sense, I think
all social theorizing
might be thought to be utopian.
Confinement, captivity,
and carceral logics that
I've been discussing
are so central to our social imagination
that it's challenging
to think beyond them.
An utopian thinking is
what will help unsettle
our imaginations so we can start to expand
the horizons of possibility.
To move beyond carceral logics
and their punitive
manifestations in practice
we need what abolitionist
Erica Meiner calls for quote
"a jailbreak of the imagination"
in order to make the impossible possible.
Utopian thinking can free the imagination
from the constraints that the violent,
oppressive, and limiting social conditions
that currently exist in the U.S.
but such thinking is not
only aimed at some hope
for a peaceful future.
By imagining otherwise we
are being asked to think
in fundamentally different new ways.
And one of the new ways
I'd like to talk about
as I wind down my discussion
tonight is what I'm calling
an abolitionist ethic of care.
An abolitionist ethic of care
would focus on the particularities
of caring relationships
informed by differences in context
as well as the racial,
economic, ethnic, cultural,
and differently gendered
experiences of individuals
and those that care for in community.
An ethics of care I think is well suited
to be the basis of an
abolitionists practice.
Care ethics in more general terms
allows us to formulate
better understandings
of ethical problems.
We turn to ethical theories
in conditions of conflict,
generally all ethical theories
to gain insights into how
we might find solutions
hard to solve social and political issues.
An ethic of care addresses
situations of conflict,
of course, but also is concerned
with how people come
to see a moral problem
as a problem in the first place,
and works to develop moral imagination,
not only as a way of reframing problems,
but also as a way to
move towards more just
in settled standable solutions
to those kinds of problems.
In the exercise of moral imagination,
care ethics is attentive
to differences in power,
as well as the cultural underpinnings
of systems of exploitation,
commodification, and cruelty.
By analyzing the specific context
in which systems of power operate
care ethics is concerned about
the larger structures that allow
and contribute to various forms
of injustice and inequality.
Care ethics also directs our attention
to the specific particular people
that are involved in the conflict
and in so doing helps us
to reframe our concerns.
It encourages the development
of empathy and compassion.
But care is also a capacity
that has to be nurtured
or cared for, care needs to be nurtured
and cared for itself.
And carceral logics another
feature of carceral logic
is they detach us from care
and they promote that sort of detachment,
and abolitionists ethic
would involve reimagining
our caring relations and
encourage and deepen them.
It also requires an analysis
of the impacts of failures of care.
Both before carceral solutions are sought
when harms are committed
and in critiquing the
dehumanizing conditions
that exist in carceral spaces.
An abolitionist ethic of
care can help both victims,
and those who caused harm
reframe their experiences.
Part of the solution to
seemingly intractable conflict
is to care for oneself
in relations of respect
and also self-respect.
As feminist thinker Sara Ahmed notes,
and here she's drawing
on another feminist thinker Audre Lorde,
work, this is a quote,
"The work of self care is about
the creation of community,
fragile communities assembled
out of the experiences
of being shattered.
We reassemble ourselves
through the ordinary everyday
and often painstaking work
of looking after ourselves
and looking after each other." And quote.
And ethics of care is not meant to be
sort of condescending intervention
where care covers over pity
or some equally contemptuous attitude,
but rather it's an ethic that
works to create the conditions
in which caring for oneself
and for others are developed
practice and valued.
It's restorative and transformative work.
Carceral logics lead us
to misguided attempts
to try to bring about
some sort of justice.
As I've tried to suggest tonight,
there are alternatives
to this way of thinking
and feeling that inflicts more harm
and does very little
to fundamentally change people's attitude
towards the harm caused by these logics.
Abolitionists have been working to develop
ways of reimagining our relationships
and our responses to harm
that don't involve
punitive carceral actions.
An abolitionist ethic of care
is a promising area for
revaluing those who are harmed,
those who cause harm,
and the broader community who are impacted
not just by the pain of harms
that have been committed,
but by the harms that are inflicted
by the state in their name.
Caring, empathetic,
reimagining is what we need
to escape carceral logics,
and it's crucial to promoting
and achieving freedom.
Thanks.
I look forward to this discussion.
- Thank you, Professor
Gruen. That that was great.
Now, so please place your
questions in the Q and A,
and I'll go through
them at moderate debate.
So, let's begin, I guess,
so let's begin first with
one question which is about,
can you connect this to your work?
So you're a theorist of
the ethics of captivity.
One of the questions
saw I think very clearly
the link between your arguments
and your position on ethics.
Do you wanna talk about
that link and expand on it?
- Yeah, thanks for asking about that.
So there's work that I,
you heard me say a little
bit throughout the discussion
that I'm interested in thinking about this
in terms of animals as well,
and the ways in which species itself
might be a type of carceral logic.
And so importantly, the work
that I was thinking about
I started to realize and
this is very dangerous
and I'm well aware of the dangers.
And so I want to just highlight caveat
that these are not comparisons
between animals in captive
environments say zoos
and humans in prisons or Gulags
or other kinds of carceral enclosure.
So I'm not making a sort of
simplistic comparison here,
but I do think that the
underlying, the background ideas,
the logic that allows for the
kinds of things I talked about
disposability, incapacity, disrespect,
lack of value, permanent injury.
Those are the kinds of things that I think
are part of the conceptualization.
That's a feature of the carceral logic
that allows for an is sort of before
prior to the existence
of these carceral spaces.
And so I think there's a very tight link
between the ways in which we
imagine or humans imagine,
some humans imagine themselves
as being in a position
of just clear domination
and some scala naturae
about we're just higher up
than these other animals.
And similarly, and importantly,
the sort of racist attitudes
are very similar that
they're somehow higher,
the area and is higher up.
So I think these are part and parcel
of the same kind of project.
And I do have a project,
a book coming out with a law professor
at the University of
Denver, Justin Marceau,
in which we talk about these parallels,
it's called Carceral Logics,
Human Incarceration and Animal Captivity
That'll be out in May.
- And Professor Gruen is,
that question really
revealed, brought out the way
that your talk clearly generalized to that
in the way that your false
off-cycle position does as well.
So let's go to an edgy question,
Yale perpetuates carceral logics.
How can we use methods
of non-reformist reform
to challenge these (indistinct)?
- Well, I think I need a
little bit more context
for the specific ways
in which Yale does this.
I think it's not actually just Yale,
I mean, I do think our institution-
- Institutions like carceral
logic has shoots through
the institutions in which we do non-reform
in which we discuss these matters.
- Perfect, that's so true.
- And so how does one deal with that
kind of performative contradiction
the aren't you a hypocrite..?
- Right, yeah, no,
and I think the performative
contradiction point
is a really important one,
and I think that if you
go back to the origins
of the notion of non-reformist reforms,
it's in the context of
thinking about what to do,
can we make any small changes
or do we have to wait for
the socialist revolution?
I think that the idea of
non-reformist reforms is that,
and the reason I like using mutual aid
as a really important example of that
is that you don't go to the
system to ask the system
to help with the problem
because the system is designed
to make it so you need help
with the problem, right?
So, and this is part of the idea is that
we know people say the
prison system is broken.
No, the prison system is working
exactly the way it was designed to work.
So making modest reforms in that system
is not going to do anything
to undo this system.
And I think with every
institution, obviously,
this is part of what I was
saying at the beginning,
we're in this position where
it is really hard to imagine
outside of these structures,
I'm not pretending that
somehow philosophically
I can just sort of will this
imagination into existence
that's not at all what I'm suggesting.
It's a very, very, very hard project,
but I do think there are various ways
that we can develop
different social relations
and we can think about it in
terms of there's movement afoot
around getting rid of grades or example,
that would be something
that would be a non-reformist reform.
You could still go to school,
but you argue that we don't want grades
those are the kinds of things that I think
people can do.
Ultimately these aren't gonna be top-down
sort of changes either.
What you want to have is
in a community, in a group,
hopefully an inclusive group was multiple
people who are in multiple social
and political locations working together.
And I know that there are sort
of all sorts of activities
at Yale that are like that.
There are lots and lots of folks
who are doing really important
non-reformist reform work there and work.
- Just a codicil to the points you made.
Like Rod Fergusson points
out that the purpose
of like the university ombudsman
is to people to complain
is to undercut any student
movement that might occur,
to get people to complain
to the institution itself
to fix the problem.
So then they can make minor reforms
without challenging
the institution itself,
to make the institution itself
the place where you complain
to make sure that the institution
is always the logic governing everything.
- That's a good codicil.
Another way of thinking about that
and more pertinent in
my world lately is that,
the faculty might organize for
better benefits or better pay
and the university in sort
of endless certain members
of the faculty and says,
okay, let's give you better
benefits and you better pay,
or let's give everybody a
little bit of a benefit,
but not the full benefit.
It's sort of co-opting the problem,
and that was the exact set of debates
that went on between revolution
and reform in the early moment
when people were arguing
in favor of non-reformist reforms.
A really important question.
- Right, so, right.
So there's this structure
to institutional abolition
and we can think of
institutional abolition say,
dramatic generally, and
then there's a structure
to counter abolition which is
to allow incremental reforms.
Yeah.
- That's right.
So Jennifer Klein asks,
so, my distinguish to our
labor historian here at Yale.
To use ethics of care as
a foundation for abolition
do we need to also question
the premise of liberal citizenship
that fetishizes independence,
cares about relations oof interdependence
in our political culture
to stains and stigmatizes
anything that can be cast as dependence.
So how do we reconcile
dominance citizenship ideas
of the model you present or change them?
Also, kathi weeks
discusses utopian thinking
not as having to be fully
formed rather as bridge
to the alternative structure we want.
- Yes. Yes.
Great questions, super questions.
I highly recommend the Care Manifesto
that came out last year
by the Care Collective.
And I think it does really
think that we need it,
if you're really gonna
think about abolition
in a full blown way, which I
did not do in this talk at all,
but if we're gonna think
about it in a full-blown way,
we are absolutely going
to have to reconsider
the kind of liberal citizen
formation that exists.
And I think that there are
different forms of care ethics.
My idea of care ethics is not one
in which you can internalize
or the system can co-op care.
So sort of basically pay for care
or even make it so that
it's part of the system.
That's absolutely something
that we see happening all around,
particularly vivid in the pandemic times.
So I think that it's important
to think about an ethics of care
as a much more fundamentally
relational idea.
It isn't going to be an idea
that's based on independence
or individualism
or any of those kinds of
distinguishing detaching notions.
It's a fundamentally and I think the quote
from Sarah Modest is
making a point of this,
that the self is in inextricable
relation with others,
that this isn't what I call
entangled relation with others.
And these aren't things
to try to disentangle,
but to try to navigate,
to negotiate and to
build better relations.
And so I think absolutely
in the political realm
there will need to be a
very important discussion.
And there have there have
been people doing this work,
Joan Tronto's another who's
done really important work
in rethinking how care
can fit into rearrangement
of political relations.
- I'm still muted,
lemme turn now to a student in the class
who has two questions.
I'll start with the first and
then go to another question.
So the first is about the
reproduction of carceral logic
in cancel culture.
I'm gonna had to this,
so the argument for this statement
follows as cancel culture
is not focused on teaching
people the error of their ways,
just places them outside
the circle of public view
in a similar way to how prisons
label people as problems
and sequester them from society.
I'd love to hear your thoughts about this.
- I think that's an excellent question.
And I think that's exactly right.
I think that there is a carceral logic
that's operating in cancel culture.
I think too though, importantly,
and this is what I was trying
to get at when I didn't,
again, not didn't have time
to fully develop the idea,
but there is a kind of effective
longing as it were for
something to go right,
and I think that presumably
there's an important way
in which what we should be
recognizing in cancel culture
is that there's already
something sort of disturbed
in our thinking that makes us
want to cancel someone else.
Now that isn't to say,
so, I think I don't wanna in any way
sort of overly psychologize that longing,
I think it speaks to the ways
that our social relations
are shallow or not robust,
or there's something missing
in our social relations.
And it's in virtue of that that we develop
these kinds of us at them good,
like you guys are the good
guys and we're the bad guys.
And I think you talk about
this too in your fascism book,
but there's this us them thing
has a certain kind of hold
on us when we live in a broken state.
I guess that's what I say
when I say a broken society,
when our fundamental humanity
and our fundamental animality
isn't being addressed
or isn't being attended
to, and that developed.
So then one way to respond to that
sort of social hollowness, if you will,
is to sort of develop this.
Okay, I'm gonna cancel you
or you have to be set aside.
Now, I do wanna say this,
this brings to mind a
really important point
that I wanna make about
abolition more generally.
I think it's also really
important to keep in mind
and cancel culture is
somewhat connected to this,
that there are actually people
who we don't want to interact with.
We don't want in our
communities, we don't want,
and I'm not pretending that everybody
is somebody that we could sort
of, that we should embrace.
So I wanna also acknowledge
this isn't Pollyanna.
It might be utopian, but it's
a different kind of utopian.
It's not Pollyannish.
It's not like, oh, well
let's all get along.
No, it's nothing like that.
- So the next question from Joe Fischel
is about the relationship
between carceral logic
and punitive logic.
And what do we do
and then it shifts.
So the first question is
about analytically separating
carceral logic from punitive
logics or punitive imaginaries,
and then Professor Fischel wonders,
what do we do with sort of the desire
for libidinized retribution?
- Hmm, hmm, hmm, so, right.
I'm not separating carceral
logics from punitive logics.
There's a part of that punitive logic
that is as part of the carceral,
carceral logics subsumes that
retributives retributivists
sort of instinct or impulse,
and so then the question becomes,
okay, so, there's a
distinction to be made there.
I'm not sure it matters.
I like to think, I mean,
I like to talk about it
in terms of carceral logic
precisely because of the point
that Professor Stanley made
that I'm interested in
captivity in a general way,
punishment itself is an
interesting separate question,
but my interests are in
the captive in the carceral
and punishment is a feature
of that whole system,
but I think the idea of retributivism is,
and the impulse towards it
that feeling that I was evoking
at the beginning of my talk,
where I encouraged us to be thinking about
why it is that we want these
is particularly people in power
who abuse their power to be punished.
I think, again, I would just
go back to what I was saying
that desire and I'm not
denying that it's there
because it is there and I have it too,
but that desire is a feature
of a distorted system, right?
And I can't help but think
of Catharine MacKinnon
whenever I talk about this, which is,
essentially that we
can't really out-think,
we can't think about
what it might be like.
Catharine MacKinnon uses the sort of idea
about sexual desire,
but the notion is like,
we don't really know what it would be like
to have genuine desire
outside of patriarchy
because we live in patriarchy,
and I think the same thing as something
that I would wanna say,
I think the desires that
we have for punishment
and retribution are a feature
of the carceral system
that we live in and the carceral logic
that's colonized our thinking
and that if we're able to get
beyond that carceral logic,
and I hope we could do that
through really thinking
and imagining otherwise
through a kind of
abolitionist ethic of care
that we might actually
be able to figure out
that we're not committed to retributivism.
And in philosophy and
the philosophy of law
and philosophy of punishment
there's been a lot of debates
about sort of what is the
underlying moral, ethical,
political values that are
achieved through punishment.
And I think already this is a good example
of something that you buying
into the carceral system.
So we're gonna debate at the edges,
should it be retributive,
or should it be like we're
trying to deter people
or is this just really a
utilitarian way of dealing with,
but that already is within the system.
And my view is that we really
need to challenge the system
of thinking about why that's the way
we wanna organize our lives.
So for example,
what would we do with somebody
who was really egregious,
nobody could handle, I
dunno, put them just,
turn your back on them or
don't let them into your home,
or don't let them into your community,
or don't let them into your space.
- So, the way I understand
your response is,
but the idea don't think of carceral logic
as like a set of principles
think of it as an ideology
where an ideology is principles,
practices, and attitudes
and emotions to things.
And you've got to eliminate
the entire ideology,
the desire for retribution
as part of an ideology,
an ideology is not just a logic.
And hopefully if we get
rid of the structure,
the hypothesis is we'll
get rid of those feelings
of retribution, though it does seem to me
that the feelings of retribution
last through a number of
different forms of punishment,
even before the prison say.
The carceral logic you're trying
to get rid of is much
deeper than just the prison.
- Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Shelly asks about how we broaden this.
So professor is a very
distinguished philosopher
of disability asks,
how we include carceral
logics and abolition,
how we broaden that to
include institutions
and social phenomenons such
as nursing homes, psych wards,
group homes for disabled
people, et cetera?
- Well, that's, I mean, I put
them in that list earlier,
Shelly, professor partly because
you've done such important
and interesting work
and continue to do work
particularly through the
pandemic on these institutions,
but that's partly why
it's really important
to think about this as
just as professor Stanley
was just saying as an ideology
or as I'm thinking of
it an overarching logic
that applies beyond the prison
situation and beyond the zoo.
I think, I mean, we
really need to think about
those as canonical cases, but
there are many, many places
in which the structure
is designed precisely
to hold on to those that are
within it in a diminished way,
the institutions require that.
There's also some really important work
on deinstitutionalization that's been done
that is particularly in the
area of psychiatric institutions
that also takes an
abolition in a very special
and important direction.
So obviously I couldn't
speak to all of these issues,
including the animal issue
that is sort of close to my heart tonight,
but thank you for raising that Shelly.
- I'm gonna put myself in the queue
even though that's a slight
violation of decorum.
So I wanted to go back to
Professor Klein's question
about liberal citizenship
and ask a sort of maybe devil's
advocate kind of question
about the ethics of care
background to your work,
which so there's a way of attacking,
there's a way of going at this
which leans on liberal citizenship,
which says that what's
happening in prisons
is a violation of equality of citizenship.
And when you're asking people
to be responsible for their actions,
your considering them as equal citizens,
this is the kind of
thing that Douglas says
and what the slave is the 4th of July.
It's like, you're not dehumanizing us
because you're treating us as
responsible for our actions,
but then this method of treating
it undercuts the equality
of citizenship that taking us
as responsible for our actions
seems to presuppose,
but all of that is within the framework
of liberal citizenship.
The way I think of it,
one kind of reasoning I'm attracted to is,
well, this kind of treatment
of a fellow citizens
is incompatible with
treating them as responsible
for their actions, treating
them as equal citizens
in this more full blooded liberal sense.
What survives from that?
And that's a very different basis.
One that doesn't generalize
as much as an ethics of care view does
to say captivity of animals.
- Well, okay, so there's a lot in that,
and if I'm understanding, I mean,
I think that the problem with
the liberal citizenship model
is it, I mean, buys into,
or it's presupposes a very
specific form of agency,
a very specific form of responsibility,
a very specific form of identity
that is part of upholding
the liberal framework.
So it has this way in
which we have a framework
that imagines us as sort
of individuals outside
of social political,
familial, intimate relations.
And then it creates the conditions
for making it so that if
we don't do something,
it looks like our freedom
or agency is being violated.
I'm not making...
What I'm trying to
suggest is that sort of,
there's a self fulfilling
and a self-sustaining part
of liberal citizenship
that makes it seem and it's
not just liberal citizenship,
it's current.
I mean, it's actually, it
goes farther back in a sense,
so that there's this idea that
what it means to be responsible,
what it means to be an agent,
what it means to be a member
of a functioning ethical world,
is that I have value,
my value is tied to myself
as recognizing that value
as Professor Chris Gorse would
say, it's tethered to me.
And I wanna go back
farther than that and say,
no, that presupposition that
we somehow sort of appear
as individuals fully
formed is just a fiction,
and that fiction-
- I got that what you want to do,
but it doesn't seem, I mean,
I think in other words,
you can have a conscience
abolitionists program though,
I mean, you haven't argued
that you can, right?
But you've present,
but abolition and the
ethics of caring framework
is a much more philosophically
radical program.
Then you could imagine an
abolitionist program extending
from abolition of slavery
that's ideologically consistent with it
that remains within the liberal tradition.
- Right, right, right, right.
No, I think that, I mean,
that's a really important point,
and I think that I wasn't
arguing actually in in that vein,
I do think that there's a sense, however,
that we can get in
trouble at some juncture
if we go that route
and the trouble is that
we're reinforcing the system
that's built on,
I mean, carceral logics
come out of that system,
and so I don't know how
that system can survive
without carceral logic, but
it's an important point,
and I should probably think about,
it's a very important point
that I should probably think
about the ways in which
I didn't argue this,
but I think there is an
important sense in which
the sort of Genesis as it were,
the relationship of the
Genesis of the carceral logic
and this liberal citizen
notion is actually
I think worth my sort of
cashing out a little bit.
Thank you.
- Yeah, I mean, Murakawa
I think tries to argue
that liberalism results
in the carceral logic,
but I don't think it's,
I love Naomi Murakawa's
work, but I don't think,
I'm not completely convinced that
that it's not a contingent
fact of history,
what Murakawa describes and...
Okay, lemme go two more questions.
So, let's see.
Oh, I mean, oh, wow. Oh, sorry.
I was on the, okay.
Open, ah, here we are.
Lemme just look to see, right.
Right, Professor Klein
weighs in to point out that
the people who develop the asylum
and the penitentiary saw them as involved
in a project of care.
Right, and that's definitely one thing
even solitary confinement was envisaged
in Eastern State Penitentiary that way.
- Yeah, right. That's right, that's right,
but I think that it's important.
I mean, I think that
these notions of care,
I think the idea of care
is not just, I care,
so I'm gonna say, early
forms of solitary confinement
as Lisa Guenther so recently points out,
we're designed precisely
to care for the person
who's gone astray
and allow them time to
reflect on themselves
and to develop sort of a quiet mind,
so that they can move in a
very more productive direction.
And I think that that's partly,
I hinted at this care
as I'm understanding it
is not that sort of
condescending paternalistic
pitying sort of notion.
And there is I think important
debate amongst care theorists
about what sorts of care
we're talking about.
And there is just to go
back to your earlier point,
there's a very rich tradition
of liberal care theorists
that are developing views about
when can care be monetized,
when can it be sort of incorporated
into a sort of financial exchange,
and those sorts of questions.
That isn't the care I'm thinking about,
but of course it exists, yes.
- Professor Klein notes
on anti-hierarchical
form of collective care
is what we need.
So, again, another question from a student
who wants to hear about your thoughts
on endowment justice
activism, and in particular,
how it measures up as a kind
of non-reformist reform?
- So I think this is a really exciting
and interesting question and thinking.
I would like to hear a little bit more
about this kind of activism,
but if I'm thinking of
what it triggers for me,
it's this idea that somehow this whole,
well, maybe you can tell me
before I start launching into this.
- So, this is like asking the university
to no longer be invested in fossil fuels.
- Okay, I just wanted to make sure
that's what I was thinking,
but then I thought, wait,
maybe there's some other thing here.
Right, so, I mean, I think
these kinds of things aren't,
I don't know if they are non-reformist.
I think ultimately, and this is tricky,
but ultimately sort of
moving around capital
from one thing to another
holds onto the structure.
And so my sense is that just as divestment
in the area of fossil fuels for example
or techno solutions to climate change,
sort of all of those things are part of,
are just another form of sort
of maintaining the system.
I know that's a harsh thing to say,
but I think if you think about
non-reformist reforms seriously,
it really doesn't mean
that you can move money
from one drawer to the
other, that's to reformist.
It's not non-reformist.
What you would need to do is
take the money from that drawer
and give it to the people
who don't have any money
that would be non-reformist,
but that's not what we're talking about
when we're talking about divesting.
So I think that's just a reform,
it's not a non-reformist reform.
- Yeah, sometimes I worry
that the kinds of reforms
we ourselves get involved
in was wishful thinking
that their non-performance reforms,
but that's just simply how life is.
- Right and that's the, I
mean, I do wanna just say
this is hard.
I mean, this is hard intellectually,
this is hard emotionally,
this is hard to do in the system
and there really is no
such thing as clean hands,
no such thing as being pure,
no such thing as being righteous.
You do what you can do.
- Yeah, and as Kristie Dotson said
in that conference ran,
injustice means that
all the options are bad.
So, Anna Marie asked a
really interesting question
about the functioning of
a criminal court system
in abolishing carceral logics.
And also relatedly,
is there a difference
in wanting a conviction
for the purpose of society's
disapproval of certain actions
and not necessarily wanting incarceration?
- Yeah, so I think these are two
really interesting questions.
I don't think that the
criminal court system
that we have ever known is non-carceral.
In fact, it is carceral
logics that organizes
whichever system those might be.
And there was early systems
for those of you who are
interested in animals,
there were early systems where
animals were put on trial
for doing various things,
because animals were thought to have
agency and responsibility,
but criminal court systems are designed,
are sort of a feature of the..
Carceral logics organizes
all criminal court systems.
So it's not clear to me
that you could have a non-carceral
criminal court system.
The question, the second question though,
is a question about
maybe wanting some sort of acknowledgement
or accountability is that,
am I hearing that right
without having punishment?
And that is certainly the
project of many people
who are working in
restorative justice work
and transformative justice work.
The idea that what we want,
it's not that everybody
can do whatever they want
and there's no consequences
and nobody's gonna be upset,
nobody's going to be hurt.
That's the kind of utopianism
that I really don't like.
It's the idea instead is
that when people do harm,
when people cause harm, when
people bring about harm,
the way to address that
is not through a system
of a punitive system, a
prison system, a legal system,
it's through a system of
community accountability.
And even there, that's
what I was saying earlier.
And even through that system
of community accountability,
there may be some people
that just don't make sense
to have around us in our community,
whatever our community is.
And then we have to figure out what to do
in that kind of situation.
And I could imagine
that if a community decides
to say exile somebody
that this would to that exiled
look very much like a carceral exclusion,
and I would hope a
process would be in place.
Again, this is all
philosophical imagination.
This isn't any specific
case I'm thinking about,
but I would hope that the
process would already say that
if you aren't willing to
be willing to work with us
in community about accountability
then this will potentially be an outcome.
So it's not something that
is sprung upon somebody
who isn't aware of it.
- I'm right to think, right?
Following from your talk
that rethinking the ideology
that is carceral logic,
carceral ideology will require
rethinking every institution.
It can't be in or many institutions.
It can't be done because
you can't disaggregate the prison
from the rest of society's
institutions which replicate it.
I'm incorporating one of the questions
which is about Yale's
relation to its community,
and I'm thinking which
does involve, I think,
elements of carceral logic,
elements of but so I'm wondering,
so policing would be an
obvious one, but I'm wondering
the utopian imagination that you described
when you talk about William
Paris how much revision,
this is a society-wide revision, right?
- Yes, I mean, I think it has to be,
and I think it has to be
in multiple dimensions.
Obviously this is a sort of a project
that like what you just mentioned
in my thinking about what
this project could look like
just makes me sort of tremble
and terror of the hugeness
or the enormity of it.
So I'm not gonna feel
comfortable at all answering it
in a way that it's like, yes,
oh, this is what we need,
but I do think it has ramifications.
It has ramifications to
how we treat animals.
If you think about that,
just think about that,
just think about that for a second.
What would it take to fundamentally
rethink our relationships with that?
I mean, it really requires starting over,
going somewhere else.
It's in every part of our systems.
So I think that's part of the issue.
And I think that carceral logics
are so much a part of
everything and we can't...
Part of the utopianism for me is not just-
- Can I intervene there
just to expand on that.
So here we have a difference
between the illiberal abolitionist program
and the kind of ethics of care
abolitionists program you envision.
The liberal program would say,
prisons are inconsistent with
equal liberal citizenship.
And so this is not really
a radical revision.
We're just knocking prisons out.
And that will if Angela Davis is right,
bring back the prison, if you're just
you're leaving a prison shape footprint.
What you're saying if it's really,
if you really want to
eliminate the prison,
you have to reimagine,
have a much more fundamental reimagining,
and here is a more fundamental
reimagining I can offer.
It's not just that the
prison involves treating
some of citizens not as
liberal equal coast citizens,
it's that the whole system
needs to be thought,
and then we're not gonna do this again.
- Right, that's right.
It will, and it won't
revert back to the problem
that we currently have,
and it won't lead to a shinier,
fancier Sweden like car
prison system either.
- And, yeah.
Okay, I think let's see if there are,
oh, so there's one more question
about how an ethics of care
can be applied to quarantining
and lockdown related to COVID-19
such as Australia's Howard Springs
or whether you believe
that's relevant at all?
- I'm not sure I understand
fully the question.
I think that ethics of care, yeah-
- I think that's not a carceral situation.
- Yes, exactly.
- Okay, so thanks to
everyone for attending
and thank you Professor Gruen
for bringing our semester to an end
with that incredible
lecture that enables us
to think through this long
path we've taken this semester.
So thank you for your work and
your activism over the years.
- Thank you for having
me, it was a delight,
and thank you for your
great questions everyone.
- All right. Bye.
Bye, everyone.